L rri Tom is passionate about beijing's
history and sharing it with those who
visit China but the number of foreign
tourists has plummeted since the
covid-19 pandemic now the government is
hoping to change that triing a 15-day
visa-free period for citizens from
France Germany Italy the Netherlands
Spain and Malaysia the Chinese
government are sending out whole other
signals and welcoming people uh to China
then that is very very good and I think
think that people will also see that
that China is not you know is not on the
lockdown
anymore after 3 years of tight covid-19
restrictions China reopened its borders
in January but it's yet to draw back the
tens of millions of international
Travelers this is chenman an ancient
part of Beijing very popular with
visitors the government says the number
of tourists has returned to pre pandemic
levels but the vast majority are
domestic tourists and they're not
spending nearly as much as they used to
Chinese officials are grappling with
slowing economic growth and a crisis in
consumer confidence it's hoped the
visa-free travel will attract not just
tourists but also international business
foreign companies have been feeling that
they they're not perhaps quite as
welcome today as they were before so I
think it's important that the government
go out and signal that you know we open
for business we want to work with you
the Visa exemption will remain in place
for one year but wouldbe Travelers still
have to contend with fewer and pricier
flights as well as increased negative
sentiment towards China for its handling
of the pandemic and geopolitical and
human rights disputes with Western
countries is the D the pill to L or Tom
says the move will help broaden
understanding the political climate is
maybe also reminding people that they
need to learn about China though he
believes the number of foreign tourists
May never return to what it was before
Katrina U alzer
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz